翻訳: Yuta Kawamura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
私は
音楽や歌 絵画が大好きな
両親の元に生まれました
♪ みんなが仲が良くて ♪
♪ 朝になると ♪
私も歌が大好きなんです
今日は 私が中２の時に起きた
ある出来事と
ちょっとユニークな私の家族を通して
気付いた事を皆さんにシェアしたいと思います
私が生まれた時
両親は 2000年生まれだから
「200人抱っこ計画」をしようと考えました
その時の写真がこれです
素敵でしょ？
私が生まれる前
両親は「絶対に幸せな家庭を築く」
と決めていたそうです
幸せ家族になるためには
どうすればいいか？
父と母は本を読んだり 話を聞いたり
ドリームマップを作ってみたりもしました
そんな早川家は
両親 私 弟２人と妹の６人
わくわく楽しい幸せ家族です
私たちの家族には
「早川家憲法」というものがあります
第一稿は 2004年頃に両親が作りました
家のトイレに貼ってあって
私たち子どもは
暗唱できてしまうほどでした
「私たち家族は いつも笑っている」
「私たち家族は お互いを尊重しあっている」
「私たち家族は チームだ」 などです
そんな家に生まれた私は
200人抱っこのおかげか
物怖じせず 人の目を全く気にしない
明るくて元気な響ちゃんだったそうです
誰にでも通りすがりの人にも
10mくらい離れた人にも
「おはようございます！」
「こんにちは！」
挨拶をして回ったり
突然歌って踊り出したり
そんな響ちゃんに
幼稚園の頃 ある事件が起きました
年少さんの時に
先生に褒められてる子がいたんです
困ってる子をスッと助けた女の子を
先生がとっても褒めていたんです
「私も褒められたい
こうすれば褒めてもらえるんだ」
って思った私は
たくさん手伝って
褒められて嬉しくて
そこから「優等生 響ちゃん」が
出来上がって行きました
皆んなの意見を聞いてまとめたり
先生に話しかけて悩みを聞いたり
授業中には「ハーマイオニー」みたいに
腕が耳につくくらいピンと手をあげて
学芸会の当日には先生に
「まとめの挨拶よろしく」って
いきなり言われて
ほぼアドリブで話したこともありました
そうすると決まって
友達の親や先生などに
「響ちゃんすごいね ありがとう」って
褒めてもらえました
私はそれが嬉しかったのと同時に
「本当はこんな人間じゃないのにな」って
心のどこかで思っていました
中学校に入ってもそれは続きました
当然のように級長に推薦されて
違和感を覚えていたのに
私は断りきれず副級長になりました
その違和感はどんどん膨らんで
イライラして 何にイライラしてるのか
理由なんて何も思いつかなくて
頭が 体が 心が
気持ち悪くなっていって
ドロドロしたドブの藻みたいに
私の内側にくっついてるみたい
それでも私は その違和感に
気づかないふりをして
いい子ちゃんを続けました
クラスメイトに声をかけて
たくさん意見をあげて
入った吹奏楽部では
「来年の木管リーダーは
響ちゃんじゃない？」って
噂になったりもしました
でも 限界だったのか
ついに中２の夏
起き上がれなくなってしまいました
体調を崩して
病院では「ホルモン過多」と診断されました
ホルモン過多とは
女性ホルモンが過剰分泌されて
体調不良を引き起こす症状です
私の場合 体がパンパンにむくんだり
立っていられないほどのめまいがしたり
そして学校に行けなくなりました
体調が悪い日だけじゃなくて
体調がいい日も学校には行きませんでした
何故行かないのか 自分でも分からず
ただモヤモヤしていました
それを助けてくれたのは母でした
「そのモヤモヤを何でもいいから
ノートに書いてみたら？」
布団の中に潜っていた私は
その言葉に ペンを持ち
紙の前に座りました
その時は何を書いているのか
よく分からないまま
頭に浮かんだまま
紙にペンを走らせました
落ち着いて書いてる時もあれば
パニック状態で
「ああー」とか「ううー」とか
書いてる時もありました
「分からない分からない」って
後からそのノートを読むと
自分が客観的に見えてきます
ある日 読んで気づいたのは
「怒り」でした
私は 部活の顧問の先生に
怒っていました
その先生は音楽が大好きで
とても熱心に教えてくださる方で
私はとても尊敬しているんですが
怒る時に一生懸命になりすぎて
人格を否定したような
言い方をしていたんです
その先生に 私は怒っていました
でも 長いこと
いい子ちゃんをやってきた私は
自分の中にそんな闇の感情があるのが
信じられませんでした
またモヤモヤしてきました
そして布団に潜ります
そこへ母が紙とペンを
持ってきてくれました
また私は 何も考えず
紙にペンを走らせます
次の日 落ち着いてから読むと
そこにはやっぱり
先生への怒りが書いてありました
自分の気持ちが目で見てわかるんです
これはもう認めざるを得ません
私は 放課後にアポを取って
学校に行きました
そしてノートを見せながら
先生と二人で話をしました
先生は泣きながら私の話を聞いてくれて
「伝わった」って思いました
でも それからも
先生は変わりませんでした
そして気付いたんです
このモヤモヤは
私が作り出しているんだって
先生に怒らされているのではなく
私がこの人に怒ってるんだと
もう一度ノートを見ました
ちゃんと見ると
先生自身が憎いんじゃなくて
先生の見方とか考え方が許せないんです
ノートに書いて見えるようにしたことで
客観的に自分の怒りを
見ることができたんです
今でもこのノートを見ると
怒りと憎しみが湧いてきます
でもそれは 前ほど
嫌なものじゃありません
受け入れたことで
「自分にはこんな感情もあるんだ」と
自分を否定することはなくなりました
一つの事実を
私は一つの塊で捉えていました
こんな感じに
でもその一つの事実は
一つの塊ではなく
たくさんの塊が重なり合ってできている
出来事の一部なんだと気付きました
そしてその塊には
それぞれから作り出される感情があります
同じ出来事でも
選ぶ塊によって感情が変わってきます
だからどんなふうにも
感じることができるんです
私はこの出来事を
「憎しみで辛い出来事」から
「大切なことに気付くことができた出来事」
と捉え直すことで
「受け入れられない怒り」は
「受け入れられる怒り」に変わったんです
そして
たくさんの出来事が
この世界には溢れています
辛い出来事以外にも
私たちの周りには
たくさんの感情で溢れています
今自分はどういたいのか？
どんな自分が好きなのか？
それによって たくさんある出来事の中から
今自分に必要なものを選ぶんです
今 この瞬間からも選べるんです
怒り 悲しみ 嬉しさ 楽しさ —
他にも たくさんの感情に
囲まれながら生きています
どの感情を選ぶかは
自分で決められるんです
パニックに陥った時
気持ちがぐしゃぐしゃになった時
私は 今その現状を知ることで
客観的に自分を見ることができ
どうしたいかが分かってきました
その現状を知るために
何でもいいからノートに書くという作業が
私にはしっくりきました
パニックになっても
ぐしゃぐしゃになってもいいんです
むしろなった方が
おっきくなれるかもしれません
私は 自分が好きになりました
私は今 どういたいのか
どんな自分が好きなのか
それによって
たくさんある出来事の中から
自分が好きなものを選び 考え
行動できる大人に
なっていきたいと思います
自分の事が分かり始めた私は
早川家の憲法に疑問が出てきました
いつも笑顔じゃなくても良くない？
いつもプラスの言葉を
使ってなくてもよくない？
怒りたい気分の時もあるもん
それを両親に言うと
「その言葉を待っていた
私たちはこう思って憲法を作ったけど
２人だけで作ったんだ
さあ家族会議しよう」
まず「私たち家族はいつも笑っている」
という部分が
「自分で自分の機嫌をとっている」
になりました
私の中で一番大きかったのは
私の「いつも笑っている必要はないと思う」
という意見と
父の思いが重なった瞬間です
前までは どんな状況であれ
いつも笑っていられる
精神的にゆとりを作るために
何でも良い方に捉えて
自分の闇を見ないようにというか
負の感情を作らないようにしていたんですが
憲法改正してからは
自分の負の感情も
出せるようになってきました
そして憲法改定版には
「私たち家族は人生を
思いっきり楽しんでいる」
「やりたいことがやれる環境である」
があります
私も成長し
今やりたいことがたくさん出てきました
家族はそれを受け入れて 応援し
困った時には
いつでもサポートしてくれます
もちろん父も母も弟も妹も
今やりたいことをやっています
私もそれを応援し
サポートしていきます
最初に両親が作った
「私たち家族はチームだ」は
今も活きています
私たち家族が一番
大切にしてることだからです
チームとは お互いが対等に
協力し合って 尊重し合って
役割を果たしている集団 仲間だと
私は思っています
子どもたちがこうやって
意見を言えるようになり
会議ができるようになったということは
早川家がチームっぽくなってきた
ということだと思います
これからも私たち家族は
家族の成長に合わせて
誰かが意見を言いたい時
誰かが新しいことに気付いた時に
また家族会議が開かれ
憲法は改正されていくんだと思います
そしてその変化こそが
私たちの求める「幸せ家族」のかたち
なんじゃないかなと私は思い始めています
ありがとうございました
(拍手)